while the date of krampus's origin has
seemingly been lost to time the holiday
traditions that he represents ironically
Trace back even before Christmas and
cromus only became associated with the
holiday once it became widespread it's
believed that the Romans were one of the
biggest celebrators of the winter
solstice the longest night of the year
in the northern hemisphere the most
popular holiday on the ancient Roman
Calendar was saturnalia a celebration of
Saturn the god of Agriculture and time
as with many ancient traditions this was
all about farming rituals people would
offer gifts to the Gods in hopes that it
would bless their winter sewing season
which is basically just when it was time
to get the seeds in the cold ground as
described in the song sewing season by
bran nit satalia started as just one day
but then they just said screw it let's
just make it a whole week so it lasted
from December 17th to December 25th it's
a lot like how Christmas in America
lasts several months before the actual
day which is super annoying